JEREMY WALKER: Hi, my
name's Jeremy Walker.
I'm a Developer
Advocate at Google.
And I'm joined here by
Max Kanat-Alexander.
We're finishing our talk
on the three software
flaws in software design.
So now you're going
to talk a little bit
about the method
of software design
that helps you
avoid all of them.
Can you give us a
little more information?
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER: Sure, so
I call this system Incremental
Development and Design.
I used a bunch of English words
because I'm generally opposed
to buzz words.
And so I just spelled
it out as like a bunch
of words that actually
mean what they mean.
Instead of some word that I
invented to sell consulting.
Before I start into this, let
me say that as far as I know,
this system works.
And it always works
as long as you
do the actual system
and not something else,
and don't add something to it.
If you do this, and
it doesn't work,
then you can email
me and tell me.
And either I will
publish something
that fixes what I said,
or I will tell you
what you did wrong.
And my email is
max@codesimplicity.com.
So, many people have heard about
incremental development, where
you just write one
thing, and then you
write another thing
on top of that,
and then you write another
thing on top of that.
And many people practice this.
What I'm adding to that
is incremental development
and design.
Because a lot of
what people do is,
they design something
up front, and then they
make incremental
steps toward it.
But what I try to do
is I try to rethink
my design at every step.
At every increment,
I rethink my design.
And what I say is, every time
I want to add something new,
the resulting system should
look like I designed it
from the beginning to do
exactly what it does now.
This involves a
lot of refactoring.
So get really good
at refactoring.
At first, it will be a
little slower for you,
but over time it will
pick up, and also you'll
get real good at refactoring.
Like, I've got really
good at refactoring
after I started to do this.
You can do it real
fast, I promise.
But it's slow at first,
but you know, keep it up.
The only important
thing is that you
need to have a general notion
of the order in which you
should build things.
Because if you do things
in the wrong sequence,
then this system won't work.
In general, you want to kind
of build from the inside out.
So the way that I
would think about this
is, like if I was
building a YouTube app,
the first thing that I would
build is the video player.
Because that's the core
of the application.
That's the thing that users
are actually trying to do.
And you can also
think of it as what
produces a useful product
as fast as possible.
So like the last time I wrote
a YouTube app, the first thing
I did was I just
made a rendering
surface that could play a video.
And that was it.
And it's not a very
useful application
but you could give it-- I could
have given it to a software
developer and
said, hey look, you
can change the Video
ID string in here,
and you can watch any
video that you want.
It's kind of useful.
It's more useful than if
I had implemented, say,
the browse interface first.
You don't want to be able
to browse videos and not
watch them.
That's not useful.
But being able to
watch them is useful.
So you want to find the useful
core and write that first.
Or the example that I give
in the book for ordering
is, if you wanted to
write a calculator
that did simple arithmetic,
addition, subtraction,
multiplication, and division.
You would want to do either
addition or subtraction first.
Probably addition because
it's sort of the base
that other things build
on, and then subtraction
you could implement
as a form of addition.
And then on top of that, you
can implement multiplication
because multiplication
is a form of addition.
Right?
And probably
subtraction is simpler,
so you probably start with that
and then do multiplication.
And then finally,
you do division
because division is
the operation that
depends on all the other ones.
The ordering of the first
two is not as important.
So subtraction and addition.
Or whether you do subtraction
or multiplication first
doesn't matter.
But you would never, ever
want to do division first
because you wouldn't have built
up all the correct abstractions
or simplicities for
addition and subtraction.
So let's give an
example of this.
So let's say that we're
going to implement a socket.
And we know that we need
sort of Unix sockets
and UDP sockets and TCP sockets.
So the first step
we want to do is
we want to write-- we just
decided to write a UNIX socket.
We've decided that
that's probably
the simplest socket
that we need.
And so first we
just write a class
called Socket and SocketTest.
And this follows all
of our previous rules
about the
implementation of things
for the three flaws
of software design.
Because you notice there's
no generic system here.
Like our first
step looks like we
designed a system that
only does Unix Sockets.
So there's just a
class called Socket,
and then there's a
test called SocketTest.
Now we're going to
add UDP Sockets.
Don't do this by
adding IF statements.
Don't hack it in.
Redesign the system to
look like it was originally
designed to do exactly
these two things.
So now we now
create a superclass,
an abstract superclass
called Socket.
And then two subclasses called
UnixSocket and UdpSocket.
And then we create tests for
both of those concrete classes.
And then we might need a
base class for the tests
because they might need to share
information between the two
tests.
So they might need
a utility module
that has utility
functions that they share.
But we wouldn't
write any of that.
We wouldn't write any of that
generic bit until we needed it.
Now the third step
is, we need TCP.
So now we have two
kinds of IP Sockets.
So now we need to abstract
out an IP superclass that
inherits from the
main Socket class
and then gives us
UdpSocket and TcpSocket.
And this looks
exactly like it was
designed to do all these things.
And then we also might need
to share code between the two,
UdpSocket and TcpSocket
tests for IP related things.
But notice we didn't pull out
IP from TCP until we needed it.
Now, depending on
specifics of your design,
you might have found that it
was simple to have an IP Class,
but I suspect that not.
I suspect that like,
parsing the IP Headers
and then parsing the TCP Headers
would actually had been simpler
to start off if you were only
writing TCP in one class.
I don't know for sure, but
maybe it would have been.
And so, that gives
us an overview
of the system of Incremental
Development and Design.
I talk a little bit more
about it in the book,
and I also talk a little bit
more about it on my blog.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
Well, I had a couple
questions I wanted to ask you.
You'd given this talk
in another environment,
and there's some questions
that came up there
that I thought were
great, that I thought
the audience would love to hear.
And the first one is,
if your main users are
in a certain language,
what's the best
way to build in
internationalization
off the bat?
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER: Sure.
So this question
deals with a point
that I made earlier in
one of our previous talks.
About that
internationalization is
something that's really
hard to bolt on later.
So you need to sort of
know about it in advance.
But you don't want
to be too generic.
You don't want to go beyond your
incremental development step,
right?
And so, what you want is,
you want some sort of layer
or some really simple
code that allows
you to add internationalization
in the future
but doesn't implement it now.
So for example, if
you're using gettext,
you have the underscore method
that you can surround strings
by.
So just make sure
that every string
is surrounded by the
right method that
would do the translation because
that's really the hard part.
The hard part is
figuring out the strings.
Making sure that you're not
trying to build sentences out
of words because you can't
translate things that way,
because you have to
translate whole sentences.
Just implement good
practices at the beginning
that have to do with
internationalization
but which don't add any
significant complexity
to your development.
JEREMY WALKER: OK,
so adding on to that,
you said,
internationalization is
something that's
really hard to bolt
on later after
you've made the app.
Could you give a couple
items that you've
seen in your experience that are
just as hard to bolt on later
that people should think
about ahead of time?
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER: So the
first thing that comes to mind
is unit tests.
It is really, really
hard to add unit tests
to a system that was not
designed for unit tests.
People start off,
they think, well, I'll
just write some big
end to end test.
Because my system is really
simple, and that's all
I need to do.
But then once your system
reaches 50,000 or 100,00 lines,
and you want to go back and try
to unit test all the things.
And you've designed
them in a way
that for example, they're
all tied to the database.
So Bugzilla was
designed this way,
where I didn't have
any unit tests,
and everything was designed
as the constructor would
load things from the database.
And that is really,
really hard to test.
Particularly when the
constructor is writing raw SQL.
So there's not even like a
layer that you can mock out
that can give you
the data you need.
So that is probably the first
thing that comes to mind.
I'm sure there's other
things, but that's sort of
like the big one.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
So when you train people
in these three flaws
and how to avoid them, and you
go back and look at their code
maybe two or three months later,
what's their biggest failing?
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER: That
they didn't believe me.
Because this is not my opinion.
This is not me stating
something that like, oh,
I think this is
what I should do.
This is actually the result
of a fair bit of research
and experience and
experiment that I
did to develop the laws in
the book and these rules.
So it's not just me
saying like, well I
think you should do this because
I'm some sort of authority.
You could-- you don't
have to ignore it.
You can ignore me or not
know anything about me,
and these should still be true.
You don't respect me or
talk to me or anything.
Or hire me to do anything.
But people, they just didn't--
they weren't strict enough.
They thought, well I can
be too generic sometimes.
Or I can-- this is
really a situation
where I just need to
be overly generic.
Or I'm sure that I
can write this code,
even though I'm only
going to need it--
you know, I'm just going
to need it tomorrow,
and I'll just write it now.
And they just didn't actually
follow the laws or the rules
here completely as though
they were actual rules.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
And the last question
we got was around tools.
I mean, I feel like you
kind of explained it
with the incremental design.
But is there any other
tools you suggest
using to help you
avoid the three flaws?
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER: Yeah.
I think having a really
strong code review
process is really good.
Having automated
dead code detection
can be really helpful.
Particularly code that's
only run by tests.
So you have code
that doesn't actually
get used anywhere
in your system even
though it gets
exercised by tests.
Which is by the way,
occasionally OK.
If the only time that
I remember, like,
well-- whenever
a developer says,
no, I'm really going to use
this in like five minutes.
I'm really going to
use it in five minutes.
Like my next change is
going to use this code.
I say, OK well, write a test.
So that way, at least it's
being used by something
so that I can prove that
it's actually useful,
or I can see an API
that makes sense.
But I still try to say like,
just wait until-- normally I
would say just wait until
you need it in the next time.
So I would say
code review tools.
You know, having a
good bug tracker.
Having a good way to keep
track of either cleanup tasks
or refactorings that you
need to do can really help.
But really, code review and
discipline surrounding that
is probably the
most important tool.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
Well Max, thanks for taking
the time to meet with us
and talk through the three
flaws and ways to avoid them.
We really appreciate that.
And thank you, audience,
for joining us.
Again, if this is the
first video you've seen,
we have a whole series.
Please check them out.
And we hope to see you soon.